e lo ha guardato dei
la prima volta che sono stato negli
stati uniti
con miami e ogni volta che entravo in un
negozio un locale pubblico mi
accoglievano con questo saluto e
l'augurio chiude ed io da educato
ragazzo di provincia
rispondevo bene grazie è lei insomma ci
sono voluti qualche negozio qualche
risatina sotto i baffi per farmi capire
che non era la risposta giusta bisogna
vivere semplicemente e lo è poi questo
senso di disagio che mi ha accompagnato
in questa esperienza di miami lo sento
ancora quando faccio una telefonata
e anche se con l'altra persona ho
parlato di cose difficili ho parlato di
momenti tragici della settimana grandi
preoccupazioni non resisto a finire con
la frase bene ecco questa rassicurazione
che io ho distintiva mente che mi sembra
che molti altri abbiano è un po un
esempio di come non ci rassicuriamo noi
ci rassicuriamo nostro spesso evitando
evitando di affrontare quello che di cui
abbiamo paura che non conosciamo
provando a nascondere alcune parti della
nostra della nostra vita che per paura
dell'opinione degli altri perché lo
facciamo beh è difficile da dire senza
dubbio abbiamo il diritto di proteggerci
però dall'altra parte un po questo mondo
di cui facciamo parte che ci spinge a
farlo dobbiamo essere sempre per tanti
sempre bellissimi sempre intelligenti
sempre brillanti conti col sorriso per
un self ii con amici fantastici effetti
di successo
insomma forse anche il mondo dei social
a esponenziali dato questo approccio e
ci ha portato a essere sempre sempre
giusti a nascondere i nostri i nostri
punti deboli
quindi siamo un po come questo pesce che
sotto è fragile sopra invece deve
mostrare una una pinna da squalo eppure
tutto questo ha prodotto è una tragedia
nella storia in qualche modo proprio
questo tipo di confronto ha prodotto
molti problemi ma anche recentemente
sappiamo che in relazione a proprio
questa logica dei social in numero di
suicidi le quantità di persone che hanno
bisogno di assistenza psicologica perché
si sentono inadeguate e salito
esponenzialmente
ma io non penso che sia la strada giusta
io penso che invece per rassicurarci
dobbiamo affrontare le nostre paure
dobbiamo affrontare avere il coraggio di
essere quello che siamo capire
profondamente i nostri limiti
del resto se ci pensiamo e anche la
storia del davide di questo mito che
rappresenta la città di firenze e che
soltanto perché hp va bene il suo limite
la sua inferiorità fisica di forza
rispetto a golia è riuscito a trovare la
soluzione vincente è la statua di
michelangelo che racconta appunto
firenze nella tensione che ha nella mano
nella fionda rappresenta proprio questo
approccio
io sono stato convinto che questo fosse
anche il percorso giusto grazie
all'esperienza che ho fatto e due città
da città che fanno parte della mia vita
rosita bellissime entrambe patrimonio
dell'umanità per l'unesco e ogni anno
dissi tate da milioni di persone
firenze che matera queste due città
hanno entrambe due profonde ferite
a firenze nel 1966 una violentissima
alluvione ha minacciato seriamente il
patrimonio storico della città ma
soprattutto ha creato motti distruzioni
e ha lasciato un segno importante nella
città a matera nel 1950 il governo
definirà città una vergogna d'italia per
il modo in cui le persone abitavano
quello che poi che oggi sarebbe il
centro storico e che allora era la città
l'italia stava cambiando il 1950 e il
governo in qualche modo stava pensando a
trasformare una paese profondamente
rurale con una grande tradizione rurale
del paese
una vocazione industriale matera
rappresentava la vergogna perché si
viveva in un certo modo ma soprattutto
perché era la penna esempio importante
della cultura di una certa cultura
rurale matera quindi venne sfollata ex
legge nel 1952 una legge portò quasi
16mila persone a spostarsi ad
abbandonare quel posto quasi che
dimenticando abbandonando lasciando alle
spalle quella città si cancellasse anche
quella vergogna che invece in qualche
modo è rimasta anche nella percezione
degli abitanti
quarant'anni dopo la città di matera
stata riconosciuta patrimonio
dell'unesco e quindi è diventata anche
un simbolo del riscatto il ribaltamento
proprio per alcuni valori che sono il
soggetto storico invece firenze firenze
è stata profondamente colpita da questo
da questa alluvione e gradualmente
accelerato quel passaggio di abbandono
del fiume trasformando in quell'area che
per molti secoli era stata il centro
della vita sociale degli scambi
economici anche un luogo di riferimento
della vita culturale in un
retro della città e quindi le persone
non andavano più vicino al fiume bene
grazie alla collaborazione con alcuni
amici ho potuto affrontare queste queste
paure e questi problemi provando a
capire se fossero delle risorse a
firenze con il mio collettivo d'artisti
formato da me vincenzo fiore è un verso
daina che qui vediamo né una posa
lavorativa abbiamo deciso di affrontare
un simbolo dell'abbandono che era uno
spazio di quasi 10 mila metri quadri
sulla sponda dell'arno appunto ritenuto
che era il segno dell'abbandono del
fiume e lo abbiamo deciso di affrontare
anche perché un signore un entomologo un
paesaggista francese che si chiama il
clay mann più o meno negli stessi anni
ci aveva insegnato che nei residui delle
organizzazione razionale dell'uomo si
nasconde un immensa ricchezza un
paesaggio perso contro un paesaggio
dimenticato lontano che non considerato
delle erbacce che però mantengono una
grandissima ricchezza evolutiva per
incoraggiati da clement
abbiamo provato a chiedere alle persone
che normalmente radevano al suolo questa
vegetazione per rendere lo spazio pulito
abbassa gli abbiamo chiesto di passare
secondo un disegno che noi avevamo in
mente a creare un giardino cosa abbiamo
scoperto abbiamo scoperto che ci
schermando aveva ragione è che proprio
in quella vegetazione spontanea in
quelle erbacce si nascondeva una
sorprendente diversità è ricchezza
biologica e soprattutto abbiamo scoperto
che tagliando delle strade in mezzo alla
vegetazione spontanea si apriva un'altra
prospettiva della città un rapporto con
la città monumentale diverso è un nuovo
rapporto un possibile rinnovato rapporto
con il fiume oggi il terzo giardino così
si chiama appunto
nella teoria di lecco emana è un parco
della città aperto a tutti i 24 ore su
24 nel quale si può provare questa
esperienza mentre a matera assieme a
tante amiche principalmente assieme a
nemico girl cristina menta che anche in
questa slide sono ritratte in una tipica
posa lavorativa
abbiamo deciso di usare la vergogna di
matera come elemento che la rendesse
unica quando matera si stava candidando
a capitale europea della cultura e lo
abbiamo deciso di fare anche perché un
antropologo americano che si chiama
michael hersfeld ha coniato nel 1995 una
teoria che ci affascinava che quella
della cultural intimacy cioè ex calder
sostiene che le persone non si uniscono
soltanto perché condividono dei valori
positivi
siamo i più ricchi siamo più forti siamo
più intelligenti ma si possono sentire
profondamente uniti anche da un senso di
imbarazzo che la società gli impone per
quello che sono
però quando questo senso di imbarazzo
viene riconosciuto quando si attiva
questa intimità culturale tra due
persone lì è possibile che emerga il
seme la scintilla per l'evoluzione
sociale e culturale e che queste persone
immediatamente riscoprono di non doversi
vergognare e rivendicare i loro diritti
e successo così per i diritti delle
persone per le minoranze etniche per
quei luoghi dove la differenza di di
pelle era un elemento fondamentale nella
determinazione delle persone e quindi
forti di del concetto di calcio a lenti
mesi abbiamo deciso di fare una seduta
psicanalitica collettiva per
l'architettura europea ovvero di porre
alla all'europa la domanda di quali
architetture si stava vergogna
quindi iniziare a parlare
dell'architettura non come di solito si
fa attraverso la le più belle
architetture ma provando a chiedere le
persone di quali architetto che si
vergognavano trovando a capire se ci
fosse del ci fossero delle ragioni per
vergognarsene oppure se in realtà con le
vergogne potevano essere riscattate e
riscattando le si potevano scoprire dei
nuovi valori questo nostro percorso in
realtà aveva una seconda traccia nella
seconda faccia era quella di parlare
dell'identità culturale dell'europa
contemporanea attraverso un percorso dal
basso ovvero creare un ragionamento
sull'intimità culturale che ci facesse
capire che cos'è l'europa oggi quali
sono i valori condivisi
oggi proprio attraverso il sentimento
della vergogna proprio partendo da una
condivisione di una profonda umanità per
circa due anni o tre anni abbiamo
portato questa ricerca in europa e nel
mondo e l'abbiamo raccolta in una mostra
all'interno della capitale europea della
cultura che diciamo è stata matera nel
2019 e dove tutte queste vergogne si
dimostravano nella loro complessità e
soprattutto l'abbiamo raccontata in una
mossa che si apriva il 23 luglio del
2019 a 69 anni da quella data in cui
probabilmente il l'allora presidente del
consiglio alcide de gasperi associava
per la prima volta la vergogna a matera
bene noi abbiamo festeggiato il la
riscossa della vergogna ovvero non più
qualità di condanna
nei confronti di un popolo di un modo di
esistere ma bensì strumento per la
condivisione strumento per la
riconoscimento di possibili valori per
l'evoluzione
io non vorrei chiudere questo mio
piccolo intervento però con l'idea che
si può parlare di vergogne di paure
soltanto attraverso i successi parlando
di successi piccoli anche con anche
piccoli come quelli di cui vi ho parlato
ma perché io penso che si debba parlare
di questi temi affrontandoli soprattutto
quando diventa quando sempre sono
giganteschi e c'è una gigante del nostro
tempo che ci ha insegnato a farlo nel
1991 una giornalista francese
intervistava giovanni falcone quando
questo magistrato era all'apice della
sua battaglia contro la mafia e in quel
momento la giornalista li faceva una
domanda semplice diceva mi scusi ma lì
non ha paura come in quel momento
rispondeva l'importante non è stabilire
se uno ha paura ma imparare a non
farsene condizionare
eppure giovanni falcone un anno dopo
veniva ucciso ucciso con la moglie
veniva ucciso con la sua scorta di cui
sopravviveva soltanto una persona e si
può pensare che abbia perso ma in realtà
proprio in questa sua ammissione di
profonda umanità nella sua capacità di
trasmettere a tutti noi che la la
battaglia contro la mafia contro le
ingiustizie non viene condotta da eroi
che non hanno paura di morire che non
hanno paura per le proprie famiglie che
non hanno paura di soffrire di rischiare
se stessi e le persone che gli stanno
accanto
ma viene condotta proprio da chi conosce
con la paura ma non può farne altrimenti
non se ne viene viene
vincolata bene questo immenso
insegnamento di giovanni falcone e la
sua vera vittoria nonostante nonostante
falcone non ci sia più nel nostro
piccolo
noi continuiamo a quindi portare l'idea
di una discussione sulla vergogna in
europa non per portare un successo ma
per affrontare sinceramente il tema dei
valori dell'europa contemporanea
attraverso ciò che ci la razza e allo
stesso tempo
noi speriamo che le persone che vadano
che vanno al terzo giardino non si
avvicinino al fiume per non avere più
paura matta di imparare a costruire un
nuovo rapporto per averne un rispetto e
attraverso questo rispetto imparare a
convivere con l'ecosistema è consolidare
un valore importante per il futuro
dopo questa esperienza io sono sicuro
che la prossima volta che andrò a miami
entrando in un negozio quando la
commessa o il commesso mi diranno el
houari today tiro bene grazie
e lei